Hi. Welcome back and congratulations! We've made it all the way to Week 7.
We've done a lot along the way, and this week's going to be a little bit different.
First and most important. We have the final exam.
There's a bunch of programming problems for you, and you'll see those.
There won't be any video associated with it--just the questions, so work on those.
I think you'll have fund doing them, and I think you'll be able to handle them all.
In addition to that, I didn't want to have any extra-heavy materials,
because you're going to have plenty of work on the final exam.
Instead, we're going to take some field trips.
We're going to go visit with some friends and colleagues of mine
who are experts in computer science who use programming everyday
and have their own views on what the process of computer program design is like.
I think you'll enjoy talking with them. Come on with us.